welcome welcome to Carnegie Mellon
University's orientation for the class
of 2020 - plus we are so excited to have
you here this morning I read the letter
oh my gosh I think I started screaming
as soon as I read the word
congratulations I just stopped reading
my mom was with me we were both cheering
it was just like a dream come true for
me personally I wanted to study business
but with a more technological edge I'm
learning industry level skills that's a
head start that's an advantage
my parents were with me on move-in day I
still miss him every day and my brother
can't forget you okay they got to see
where I was going and they could have
faith and I was in a good place
orientation we definitely helped a lot
don't be afraid to explore ask questions
meet as many people as you can
my best friends were from orientation
week I had to tell myself to just soak
it all in just embrace the awkward my
best advice to you is go to an event as
soon as you find one work hard but also
play hard if you want to try something
new go for it if that doesn't work out
then no try for something else there's
so many possibilities Gold hackathon
return at ease and sororities black
singers even the ballroom dance team if
you're interested the service is a way
to take a step back and look at what's
going around me not just that myself
what I really get my memories from are
these extracurriculars and the friends
that I think you're among the brightest
equal we're all driven and we're also
passionate there's just really a sense
of cooperativeness there are always
people around going to support you the
faculty have always been there for me I
can go to them after class and just talk
to them not even just about class but
about life that's the culture it's email
I'm an advocate I'm an entrepreneur I'm
a code breaker because I break all my
code if you're afraid of making mistakes
don't be all of my successes come after
failures how you pick yourself up is
what's really important seeing it has
made me a different person when I walk
across campus I feel like I'm at home
there's a lot of space here for
creativity for excitement people are
building creating anything is possible
don't be afraid to diverge from your
path whatever you do just give your all
no matter what the outcome might be my
heart isn't the work my heart is in the
work my heart is in the work a very
special thank you to Seung Jun Hong
Lauren Lazaro and Jorge Alvarez for
their great reflections we hope the
video gives you a sneak peek at life as
a student and the exciting possibilities
that await you here at CMU it is now my
pleasure to welcome all faculty staff
current students parents and families
and of course our new students in the
class of 2020 to plus we hope the video
gives you a sneak peek at the life of
the student and the exciting
possibilities that await Oh a special
welcome to our senior leadership and
alumni board volunteers to our new
students let me be among the first to
welcome you formally to your new school
your new campus and what we hope will
become your new home today's welcome
program will give you the opportunity to
hear from important members of
university leadership including
president Farnum Jahan Ian and vice
president of student affairs Gina castle
II know my name is Lily Marty and I'm
one of the seven head orientation
counselors who have been working hard to
plan the orientation program for our new
first-year students it is an honor to be
up here representing the team I know I
speak for the entire orientation staff
when I say we are so excited the first
year students are finally here we have
crafted in an exciting and intentional
orientation program to help our entering
students learn what it means to be a
part of our community and to get you
connected to campus resources and
mentors I can't wait for our first year
students to learn more about this
university that I love so much it is now
my pleasure to introduce Alex de Claudio
the president of Carnegie Mellon
University's Alumni Association Alex
holds an economics degree from Dietrich
College and a Masters of Arts management
from Heinz Hall
during his student days he was in both
scotch and soda and the kiltie band alex
currently serves as the president and
CEO of high-up enterprises an
international deep digital media company
prior he has worked as an independent
entertainment producer with credits on
Broadway in television and the popular
web series Pittsburgh dad's please join
me in welcoming Alex to Claudio to the
stage hello class of 2022 plus as Lily
said I have the distinct honor of
serving as the president of the Carnegie
Mellon Alumni Association but don't
worry I'm not here to ask you for money
not yet anyway can I ask any alumni of
Carnegie Mellon University who are here
in the tent with us to please stand if
we can see them thank you welcome thank
you for being here to support the newest
members of our community
all right first years on behalf of the
over 110,000 Carnegie Mellon University
Alumni in over 145 countries please let
me be among the first to welcome you
into the Tartan family we are so proud
to have you and your parents become
members of our community of incredibly
passionate and hardworking students
alumni faculty and staff all of us all
around the world will be supporting you
and rooting for you as you embark on
this exciting journey I know it's been a
very busy time for you as you prepared
for your move to campus as you get
acclimated to life of a CMU student I'd
like you to keep a few things in mind
your CMU experience has no limits it's
not just here on campus and in
Pittsburgh and it doesn't end after four
years this is only the beginning of what
will be your lifelong relationship with
the University I hope you're able to
cherish every moment of it as I have
just as important with you as your
relationship with CMU is the
relationship that you will build
starting this week with each other the
shared experience that you will have
with the people here in this tent with
you
today we'll forge relationships that
will hopefully last for the rest of your
lives I hope all of you take the
opportunity to open yourself to the
people who are here with you I promise
you'll learn just as much from them and
they from you as you will in your
classes you're now part of the Carnegie
Mellon Network which includes Tony Award
winners Nobel Prize winners problem
solvers entrepreneurs founders people
who are impacting their communities and
who are impacting the world as you will
no doubt hear quite a lot over the
coming years in the words of our founder
Andrew Carnegie our hearts are in the
work and it is that work that will bond
you together with the rest of the Tartan
family and speaking of work it's no
secret that you're going to be doing a
lot of it here at CMU when things get
hard or feel overwhelming I hope that
all of you will make sure to take care
of yourselves take care of each other
ask for help when you need it and don't
forget to have some fun get involved in
all the many activities on campus which
I promise you will find to be very
fulfilling on behalf of the Alumni
Association Board and Carnegie Mellon
graduates all over the world I wish you
the best of luck we're looking forward
to seeing all that the class of 2020 2
plus will accomplish now and in the
future thank you
thank you Alex up next it is an honor to
introduce Carnegie Mellon University's
10th president dr. Farnham Jahan Ian dr.
Johan Ian began his presidency this past
March by appointment of our Board of
Trustees and with the enthusiastic
support of the entire CMU community he
was previously the university's provost
and chief academic officer and was
instrumental in institutional and
academic leadership planning and
implementation known for his deep
engagement with students and his
dedication to improving their experience
on campus dr. johan ian has already had
an enormous impact on CMU he is a well
accomplished computer scientist
entrepreneur and higher education leader
and has held several other academic and
government leadership positions today
dr. Shahani and his wife tryst are proud
CMU parents to a rising senior ladies
and gentlemen the president of Carnegie
Mellon University dr. Farnham Jahan Ian
[Applause]
Thank You Lily for your kind
introduction and for your leadership
throughout orientation I also want to
express my appreciation to Alex de
claudio for his thoughtful remarks Alex
thank you for welcoming our incoming
undergraduates as they begin their
lifelong relationship with Carnegie
Mellon parents and family members on
behalf of the entire Carnegie Mellon
University community I am thrilled to
welcome you to CMU now to the class of
before I start I have a question for you
are you excited to be here oh wow we're
gonna have to try this again I think
okay to the class of 22 92 plus are you
excited to be here much better much
better first of all congratulations on
all of your achievements that have led
you to this moment you are among the
brightest most motivated exceptionally
gifted and wonderfully independent
members of your generation what we all
recognize that you have arrived here
with a little help from your loved ones
class of 2022 would you please join me
in thanking your parents and loved ones
for their support and encouragement
as you just heard my wife Trish and I
are both CMU parent I'm delighted that
Trish is here Trish would you stand up
place of you I'm also delighted that the
very special supporter of the University
our chairman Jim Rohr he's the chair of
Carnegie Mellon's Board of Trustees was
able to join us this morning Jim would
you please stand to be recognized Jim
Rohn students Jim is my boss so do me a
favor and please laugh at my jokes
that's very good thank you
Jim thank you for everything that you do
for the University and for our community
thank you so much our provost and chief
academic officer Laurie gwine Garth is
also here this morning to welcome our
increment class Laurie would you please
stand up and say hello to our students
I'm excited to introduce to you the
university's exceptional team of
academic and administrative leaders our
Dean's are here our vice Provost's are
here so I'm going to invite our Dean's
our vice provost and members of the
executive management team would you
please stand as a group and be
recognized ladies and gentlemen the
leadership of the University
but I'm not done in addition I would
like to acknowledge our dedicated
student affairs staff including
associate dean Julie Shultz and an
Whitner who are responsible for leading
our amazing first orientation and of
course I would like to welcome and thank
the many counselors leaders and Resident
Assistants here to greet you especially
our seven head orientation counselors
lily and Jameis Anna Jameson Christie
Raghav David Julie and Mason would you
please to be recognized
[Applause]
you're gonna get to know all of them
Arion counselors the leaders and and
Resident Assistants very well over the
coming week for many of you today
fulfils eighteen years of preparation
and dreams of spreading your wings
students you may be worrying a bit that
your parents will call or text you every
day to check on you but I wouldn't be so
sure the anxiety you see in their eyes
may really be a look of contemplation as
they think about what they will turn
your room into no worries while they're
busy turning your old rooms into man
caves or on Airbnb you'll be doing
something much cooler getting a great
education here at CMU I am thrilled to
be serving as president of this
university as well as a member of our
faculty but most importantly I'm proud
to be a CMU parent my daughter Sierra is
about to start her senior year but it
feels only like yesterday that Tris and
I were sitting right here where you are
now with a mixture of apprehension
worried excitement and maybe just a
little jealousy having dropped off our
children at college I can say that
nothing quite prepares you for when your
kid says no thanks mom and dad I don't
need you to stick around so be gentle on
your parents okay trust me your kid will
be okay
parents you'll be okay too you know this
is particularly a special class for
Carnegie Mellon University in fact the
class of 2022 represents a university
milestone are you ready for this we have
had more students apply to be a member
of the Carnegie Mellon class of 2022
than any other class
in the history of university we received
a record-breaking 24350 one application
a remarkable 19 percent jump over last
year
every single college and school saw a
significant increase in the number of
applications this rising applications
should make you all feel really good
it means we had to be more selective
than ever before so you can humble brag
to your friends that it's never been
harder to get into CMU than the year you
applied but students you got this you're
here because we know you can succeed and
we believe in you roughly forty one
hundred students were admitted with
about fifteen hundred and sixty-five
joining us today by the way just about
half of your class are women and more
and more of the world's best students
are choosing Carnegie Mellon over other
top institutions they could have
attended in fact about four out of ten
admitted students this year chose CMU to
come let me tell you a little bit more
about your class the class of twenty
twenty-two includes students from 45
states across this country and 16
percent of you are international
students from 30 nations from around the
world you are joining an exceptionally
multicultural and multinational
community here at CMU a true reflection
of our interconnected world our 1,400
faculty come from 48 nations and our
hundred and ten thousand alum live and
work in hundred and thirty countries
around the globe none of this is by
chance a diverse and inclusive community
is the foundation for excellence in
learning research creativity and human
development it doesn't matter if you're
from New Jersey or New Dehli CMU is
proud to welcome
into our community perhaps what makes
CMU unique is the way in which we
intertwine science technology and
business with social science with
humanities and the arts to create a rich
interdisciplinary culture our innovative
problem solving and relentless
creativity delivers work that matters in
robotics and machine learning in
artificial intelligence in fine arts and
design in business and public policy in
international in in that in the natural
and Social Sciences in advanced
manufacturing and engineering and that's
just scratching the surface some people
recognize CMU as the birthplace of
artificial intelligence others know us
as the place where a student wrote the
musical Pippin which went on to become a
Broadway sensation or for another
generation the place that produced much
of the original cast of Hamilton today
CMU alumni today CMU alumni faculty and
yes our students are tackling the
hardest challenges facing society let me
just show you a couple of example of the
kind of work we do here at CMU you know
it keeps us up at night in 20 years the
earth will have nearly 9 billion people
and not enough food so at Carnegie
Mellon University were growing food in a
whole
a new way using artificial intelligence
we analyze plans improve sustainable
growth and get solutions to farmers and
thanks to a team of really smart robots
we can keep the momentum growing there's
work to be done worldwide we do the work
that matters this is the kind of
collaborative work that sets Carnegie
Mellon apart let me show you another
example the traffic lights are talking
and the street lights and cars have
joined the conversation they are
figuring out how to load billions of
people in the most efficient way at
Carnegie Mellon University we create
intersections that actually learn so we
all get home faster safer and with 20%
fewer emissions we're not just blowing
smoke there's work to be done worldwide
we do the work that matters as you can
see we're helping to solve big societal
challenges class of 2022 you're starting
your college experience at a pivotal
time for Humanity as our society
undergoes a breathtaking pace of
technological change the future has
never been more exciting and more open
to new opportunities this generation
your generation will write this story of
this century you will advance human
knowledge drive our economy with your
ideas and shape our culture with your
creativity but as we come to understand
the impact of emerging technologies on
the future of work it's clear that you
can't just get the same kind of
education that your parents received
just consider for a moment according to
a recent study done by the manpower
group an estimated 65 percent of jobs
that your generation will perform
throughout your careers don't even exist
today if that scares you it shouldn't
why because you're here with Carnegie
Mellon's distinct strength at the
intersection of technology and society
we will provide you with a strong
foundation for decades of success in our
knowledge-based economy our innovative
approach to education will help you
become architects of a constantly
evolving future it's not just our
excellence in computation data and
technology enhanced learning that makes
us leaders in 21st century education
Carnegie Mellon we're training our
students in essential human skills that
will only increase in value as
automation pervades our world skills
such as critical thinking
problem-solving communication and of
course collaboration and we also
pioneered new interdisciplinary programs
that meet the needs of society and the
interests of today's students examples
include the integrative design art and
technology known as id eight new
offerings in neuroscience and in
computational biology as well as
first-of-a-kind program in behavioral
economics and in artificial intelligence
we've made a number of critical
investments in our infrastructure to
support this vision for higher education
we just finished the construction of a
three hundred thousand square foot
building on our new David a Tepper
quadrangle The Temper quad will serve as
the new home of our business school and
a campus-wide hub for collaboration
innovation creativity and
entrepreneurship in addition to 24
state-of-the-art classrooms it includes
our Center for technology enhanced
learning and our Center our Swart Center
for Entrepreneurship I see the Tupper
quad as the physical realization of a
new model of higher education a space
that catalyzes connection collaboration
and inspiration will celebrate the
building's grand opening on September
13th and 14th I hope you'll have the
opportunity to join us on the other side
of the campus ANSYS Hall is under
construction as the new 30,000 square
foot hub of College of Engineering's
undergraduate program as part of our
maker ecosystem this facility will
create and support resources for
students to innovate at the cutting edge
of advanced manufacturing simulation and
material design ANSYS Hall will work in
conjunction with Scott Hall the home of
our Nanofab and a Scott Institute for
energy innovation we also began this
last year investment to renovate and
innovate classrooms across campus these
renovations will enhance more than 3500
seats across campus embracing the future
of learning with hands-on collaborative
technology enhanced spaces in addition
to the world-class research and
education that goes on here we are
deeply committed to enhancing the CMU
experience for our students Carnegie
Mellon is more than a collection of
classes academic majors and departments
or a community dedicated to the personal
and intellectual growth of our students
this commitment to a holistic CMU
experience is a priority for all of us
at the University you'll hear more about
this from Gina castle a know our Dino
students a little bit later this morning
and of course throughout the entire
orientation before I wrap up first a
little advice for parents as your sons
and daughters evolve into fully form men
and women here at Carnegie Mellon let
your role evolve with them at a certain
point you'll find out that instead of
being the problem solver it's much
better to be an advisor who supports
them as they solve problems for
themselves
well you shouldn't probably call them
every day should text them every day I
do want to encourage you to stay engaged
in your children's lives and with the
University there are many opportunities
to volunteer it or get involved through
local alumni chapters are our parents
Leadership Program there are so many
opportunities to come back to our campus
in October we'd celebrate family weekend
and Homecoming weekend we also have our
carnival weekend in April which is a lot
of fun now the class of 2020 - I have
three practical pieces of advice for you
first don't be afraid to venture outside
your academic boundaries CMU is known
for producing innovative thinking at the
edges and intersection of traditional
disciplines so step outside your comfort
zone indulge in reading that's not
required volunteer at a local school or
an organization by embracing a multitude
of experiences you will create a context
for discovery and creativity beyond what
you imagined was possible second focus
on the present a wise person once said
that one of life's ultimate luxuries is
the power to choose how you spend your
time in college you have that luxury so
make every experience a meaningful one
and every interaction a learning
opportunity third and perhaps most
importantly treat yourself with care
these next four years or so will
undoubtedly be some of the most
transformative of your young lives so
take this journey slowly thoughtfully
and with attention to mind body and
spirit eat right go for a run or a bike
ride trust your instincts and be safe
make time for yourself and lean on each
other this is one of the most important
ways in which we can act as a community
and thrive as individuals
so to recap venture widely focus on the
present and take time to reflect and
take care of yourselves and each other
if you remember anything from today's
remarks let it be this you are not alone
here class of 2022 if you can already
tell we are so excited to have you here
so let me say it one more time
class of 2022 plus welcome to Carnegie
Mellon University thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
while we have a little treat for you at
this time I am thrilled to introduce his
special performance from two
exceptionally talented CMU students
Jakob Randall Holmes is a composer
songwriter vocalist and producer
he received his masters of music and
Composition and is currently completing
his advanced music study certificate
both from our School of Music this
morning
Jacob will perform a song from his
original musical elevation titled Aspen
Colorado
Jacob will be accompanied by vocalists
Zach Herman a musical theatre and acting
major in our School of Drama please join
me in extending a warm welcome to Jacob
and Zach Jacob and Zach come on to the
stage
[Applause]
inside of nowhere west of Ohio elevation
starts to climb flats turn the hills and
Hills turn to mountains when the snow
starts to arrive
and for a while it's hard to breathe but
your lungs will adjust eventually but
the only thing
[Music]
what do you do in Aspen
when the temps 22.5 degrees the wind is
howling a blizzard
but it's fine cuz we all drive s-sir and
there were 8,000 feet above the seeds
the
the altitude is hard but that's fine
with me
[Music]
where something's happening
[Applause]
there's always truth in movie puns
intended
cinematic magic starts out of now
take a champagne last
[Music]
just put your head
what you do Colorado it's a dream at
America's highest reach no spent the
last
the slopes will get you over it
the chief to streaming down your cheeks
like this whole day's been for weeks
animation sigh so just try to see you
thinking about your mother
that divorce is their love for
because who are the one changing or the
one growing
focus on you did they just
[Music]
now that you're in Aspen
your life is gone now
to be
son being the boy
dark today I promise you there's only
two
it's just not right that they just seem
to fight but if you just
will decline
so come ride with me
[Music]
[Applause]
let's give another round of applause to
our talented school of music alumnus
Jacob Randall Holmes and School of Drama
student Zac Herman thank you so much
students this is what you'll hear every
day here at Carnegie Mellon it's true
good morning my name is Gina castle Eno
and I have the privilege of serving as
Carnegie Mellon University's vice
president for student affairs and Dean
of Students I'm so pleased to join our
speakers president Jahan Ian Lilly Alex
and so many more who are here to welcome
the students and families to the
University and to orientation for the
class of 2020 two plus we have been
preparing for your arrival for months
and it is wonderful to have you join the
community while we're on rounds of
applause please join me I know this one
won't be hard in a heartfelt thank you
to the countless students alumni and
staff who volunteered to help move you
in to your house communities yesterday
[Applause]
there is not a family that I've spoken
to over the course of the last 24 hours
who has not said how amazing they all
were and there is no shortage of amazing
here at CMU you've witnessed that here
on this stage with the talent from our
College of Fine Arts programs and seeing
that in our opening video featuring sung
Estella and Jorge all members of the
team who helped welcome you to campus
yesterday
you